damit hatte niemand gerechnet
die gegner der eu gewinnen das kritische
referendum dieser dreiundzwanzigster
juni soll als unser unabhängigkeitstag
in erinnerung bleiben
reiche finanziers hatten das referendum
massiv beeinflusst
darunter der millionärin banks konnte
nie erklären woher das geld genau kam
spuren führen in russische kreise und zu
rechtsradikalen populisten in die usa
eine unheimliche allianz greift die
etablierte demokratie an digital die
ganze dynamik ändert sich in der
demokratische prozess wird untergraben
den eu gegnern war fast jedes mittel
recht
sie gewannen weil sie das gesetz
brauchen mir ist klar geworden wie
verwundet war großbritannien war und die
anderen europäischen länder sind es noch
immer die eu gegner wollen mehr
diese bewegung wird weiter wachsen und
am ende das system verändern
[Musik]
brüssel im krisenmodus der exit sprecher
des eu parlaments die verhofstadt
beschäftigt die krise in großbritannien
tag und nacht er ist überzeugt das eu
referendum wurde manipuliert
[Musik]
we have wir haben eine fünfte kolonne in
den rängen unserer europäischen familie
letzten ist
ich nenne sie putins cheerleader michael
vormarsch das gesicht der anti eu
bewegung
sie nehmen das geld und
geheimdienstinformationen des kreml
sowie erin bank sein freund von verrat
der mit den russen zusammengearbeitet
hat damit es zum wechsel kommt
verhofstadt verdacht russlands komplizen
setzen einen lange vorbereiteten plan um
mehr denn je vor ungefähr zehn jahren
hat putin seinen strategie gegenüber der
europäischen union völlig verändert
seitdem ist es seine strategie die
europäische union zu zerstören indem er
leute wie es war wie nie hüpfern wilders
und verrat unterstützt bisher nutzt
rechtsextreme und die dreckige arbeit zu
erledigen wurde der praxis wirklich von
russischen kräften manipuliert wer
könnte noch ein interesse an dem chaos
haben in das großbritannien versunken
ist
die spurensuche beginnt im zentrum des
sturms
[Musik]
du bist ein antidemokrat willst einfach
immer wieder wellen bis es passt
[Musik]
sie haben nicht ehrlich gewonnen den
menschen wurde ein großer haufen lügen
verkauft für viele der lügen wird er
verantwortlich gemacht
nigel farage mister praxis haben seine
gegner recht war ihm jedes mittel recht
sie können einfach das ergebnis nicht
akzeptieren
es passt nicht in ihre welt anschauen
etwas muss schief gelaufen sein
vielleicht war alles gelogen oder ja
russland war schuld was für eine
unglaubliche kampagne
aber da draußen in mittelengland
interessiert das sowieso niemanden
tatsächlich treibt viele menschen im
land die frage um ob das referendum
manipuliert wurde
im parlament fragte als erstes der
abgeordnete ben bradshaw haben
ausländische kräfte das referendum
beeinflusst
[Musik]
es waren gerade beweise aufgetaucht die
belegten dass sich russen in die
us-präsidentenwahl eingemischt hatten
da habe ich mich gefragt warum sollten
sie das nicht auch beim rexit versucht
haben
der abgeordnete wird auf einen freund
von verrat aufmerksam gemacht
banks millionär und brite mit guten
kontakten ins ausland längst steht im
mittelpunkt vieler vorwürfe er war einer
der köpfe der praxis kampagne von fw
lief kam zudem hatte die größte summe in
der politischen geschichte
großbritanniens gespendet auf dem weg in
den südwesten von england
hier in der nähe von bristol besitzt
alan bangs ein anwesen
der versicherungsunternehmer wählte
diese bühne um im oktober 2014 eine
spektakuläre ankündigungen zu machen
er wolle der partei von verrat eine
million pfund spenden
es ist kein großes geheimnis wir kämpfen
ständig um geld wahlen stehen an
in den letzten wochen war ich besonders
besorgt ich mache mir mehr sorgen ums
geld als um alles andere für die presse
ist banks ein nobody
das sieht ja alles aus als hätten sie
eine menge geld aber ich habe etwa 30
unternehmen wenn im diamantenabbau tätig
außerdem im versicherungs- und im
bankenwesen doch das anwesen war nur pr
kulisse es ist nicht banks wohnsitz er
vermietet das haupthaus an
hochzeitsgesellschaften sofern sie genug
zahlen
die medien stürzten sich auf banks
[Musik]
er ist milliardär und mitbegründer der
kampagne lief eur1 ist bei uns zu gast
willkommen in der renommierten financial
times durfte banks wenig später sogar
fördern dass nicht nur die eu sondern
der ganze staat in stücke gerissen
werden müsse kurz bevor er in bands ihn
reich beschenkt preis der mittel für
rasch in die hauptstadt der usa
sein ziel eine seitenstraße hinter dem
kapitol
dort war er in ein rotes backsteinhaus
eingeladen worden
die sogenannte botschaft der
online-plattform breitbarth
rechtsradikal extrem chef ist damals der
ex-banker steve bennett von der
botschaft aus verbreitet er sein mantra
der staat und das gesamte establishment
müsse zerstört werden
mit diesem radikalen ansatz bringt einen
nur zwei jahre später auch den
kandidaten trump ins weiße haus war das
eu-referendum ein testlauf
[Musik]
postiv gab mir und der kampagne eine
starke stimme in dem er uns vehement
unterstützt ich hatte zuvor keine
medienunterstützung 0 begann breitbart
uns zu helfen später der daily express
wenn man plötzlich ein paar stimmen aus
seiner seite hat macht das einen echten
unterschied nennen spielte also eine
sehr wichtige rolle
[Musik]
steve liebt es sich als das böse genie
zu verkaufen
der wie in einem james bond film eine
weiße katze streichelt aber er ist auch
ein tiefgründiger politischer denker
rennen und forsch erregt mit der
gleichen methode aufmerksamkeit
sie machten den menschen angst vor allem
europa werde von fremden menschen
überrannt verantwortlich die europäische
union
die größte diskrepanz zwischen unseren
eliten und normalen leuten besteht in
der frage wie man mit dem thema
einwanderung umgeht
ohne dieses thema hätten wir das
referendum nicht gewonnen ich hatte das
genau wie beim sehr früh verstanden
wie genau kennen und verrat ihre
botschaft unter das volk gebracht haben
erforscht drm bryant seit jahren kennen
nutzte seine plattform breitbart um das
rechte lager immer weiter zu
radikalisieren
breitbart verbreitete eine botschaft die
weiße rasse wäre überlegen verwendet
eine bestimmte rhetorik um menschen
mitzureißen sie wütend zu machen
dabei kann er auf eine kulturelle
grundlage aufbauen
sie nutzen um das feuer weiter
anzufachen als brandbeschleuniger
setzten die sozialen medien ein
er leitete eine firma mit die sich
darauf spezialisiert hatte potenzielle
wähler digital aufzuspüren
cambridge analytica das ziel menschen
zum wählen zu bewegen das mittel
maßgeschneiderte propaganda analytiker
wurde im keller der breitbart botschaft
geboren ganz in der nähe vom weißen haus
rennen nutzte die firma später um trump
ins weiße haus zu bringen
zuvor stand jedoch das eu referendum an
e mails beweisen dass brennan in die
ersten brad pitt gespräche mit cambridge
analytiker einbezogen wurde
banks der geldgeber im hintergrund stand
früh in kontakt mit dem radikalen
vordenker bahnen die eu gegner waren von
der digitalen strategie begeistert mehr
menschen konnten schneller billiger und
genauer erreicht werden welche rolle
spielte dabei cambridge analytica genau
analytiker haben wir uns angesehen sind
aber nicht ins geschäft gekommen
in amerika war die firma sehr groß in
großbritannien dagegen stand sie noch am
anfang aber ja all diese ansätze hat die
vorangetrieben es ist eine sehr neue und
effektive art politik anzugehen
doch tatsächlich erreichte das know how
von cambridge analytiker auch europa und
verrat wusste davon
die kampagne lief eu finanziert von
ferraris freund alan bangs ging ende
2015 mit der nachricht an die
öffentlichkeit dass man einen partner
von weltrang engagiert habe cambridge
analytiker hatten über 100 ländern
gearbeitet und neuartige spezialisierte
methoden angewandt
im publikum nigel farage auf dem podium
eine expertin von cambridge analytiker
bei lief ihr werden wir eine kampagne
organisieren die auf die menschen hört
dafür im ganzen land aufwendig forschen
die potenziellen wähler wurden dafür
ausspioniert mit hilfe ihres handys den
apps facebook google interessen
bewegungsprofile die brics it strategen
wollten alles wissen
wozu sie die daten brauchten erforscht
dokter martin nur wie viele menschen
glauben dass parteien und die kampagnen
sie von einer meinung überzeugen und sie
dafür in eine rationale debatte
einbinden wollen aber genau darum geht
es bei einer social media kampagne eben
nicht es geht allein um eine reaktion
die menschen sollen klicken jeder klick
bringt mehr daten mehr verständnis hilft
dabei eine kommunikationsstrategie zu
entwickeln
es brauchte nur einen anreiz als ein
parlamentarischer ausschuss endlich
viele anzeigen der mode lief kampagne
sichten konnte ging es darin auch um
tierquälerei nicht jedoch im
zusammenhang mit der eu da fielen sätze
wie wenn sie gegen den walfang sind
klicken sie hier
die emotionalen anzeigen waren der
ideale köder
klickt der nutzer hänger am haken die
digitalen strategen konnten die
potenziellen wähler dann mit
manipulativen anzeigen bombardieren
[Musik]
zum beispiel großbritannien habe bald
eine grenze mit dem irak 76 millionen
türken stünden vor der tür und man zahle
der türkei eine milliarde pfund damit
der start in die eu eintritt die
anzeigen so genannte dark es sind
oftmals glatte lügen und sie sind
maßgeschneidert
bei facebook kann nur der jeweilige
nutzer sie sehen
in einer demokratie erwarten wir dass
die dinge öffentlich diskutiert werden
wenn behauptungen aber auf einen
einzigen wähler zugeschnitten werden und
den genauen inhalt kennen nur die
kampagne die partei facebook und der
empfänger dann wird die ganze dynamik
und das demokratische prinzip verändert
der demokratische prozess wird so
untergraben
im verborgenen verbreiteten die ihm
gegner überall im land eine botschaft
geht wählen wenn ihr angst habt wenn man
will leute die mit deiner meinung
übereinstimmen dazu bringen dass sie
wirklich wählen
es geht um mobilisierung und das haben
diese jungs verstanden
wir treffen einen mann der behauptet
dass er bereit für den bhc rexit
gestimmt zu haben
er kritisiert öffentlich die
manipulation des referendums durch die
online kampagne
jeden tag wurde man über die sozialen
medien mit anzeigen von boot lief oder
lief bombardiert egal wann man bei
facebook war immer war da eine anzeige
man konnte ihnen nicht entkommen die
propaganda war überall die offizielle
austritts kampagne von gut lief
verbreitete lügen auch in der
öffentlichkeit der politiker boris
johnson verkaufte sie die botschaften
wirkten als ich dann am 23 juni 2016
wählen ging war ich immer noch
unentschieden in der wahlkabine habe ich
es dann darauf angelegt und dachte mal
gucken was passiert der brh exit könnte
super werden oder eben ein komplettes
desaster banks und orange wussten dass
bei den wählern vor allem die letzten
tage entscheidend sein würden
als die abgeordnete der labour party jo
kox kurz vor dem referendum von einem
radikalen eu-gegner ermordet wurde
wollte das land innehalten banks team
bombardierte die ziel wähler trotzdem
weiter bei facebook mit anzeigen und nur
der adressat konnte sie sehen
viele menschen entscheiden sich wofür
und ob sie überhaupt wählen wollen in
den letzten tagen oder stunden vor der
abstimmung
wenn man also genau weiß welche
informationen welche reaktion in welcher
zielgruppe auslöst kann man sich in den
letzten stunden darauf konzentrieren
diese gruppe gezielt zu mobilisieren
[Musik]
das vereinigte königreich hat für den
austritt aus der eu gestimmt
nigel farage alan bangs unterstützt von
bällen und co
sie hatten erreicht womit niemand
gerechnet hatte
wir haben es dank verdammt harte arbeit
geschafft wie die meines freundes
minister banksy
[Applaus]
die welt ist geschockt knapp mit 51 9
prozent hatten sich die briten für den
wechsel entschieden
eines fiel auf die eu gegner hatten drei
millionen wähler mobilisiert die sonst
bei wahlen zu hause geblieben waren
unter anderem in little händen im süden
englands konservativ wohlhabend bis
dahin keine hochburg der eu gegner aber
als es darauf ankam gaben hier extrem
viele wähler ihre stimme ab und fast
alle entschieden sich für den bhc rexit
[Musik]
wie genau haben die eu-gegner das
politische system so überrumpeln können
nach dem referendum weiß niemand eine
antwort als erster begibt sich doktor
martin nur auf die spur des geldes und
die ausgaben der offiziellen lief
kampagne durch als ich alles zusammen
gerechnet hatte zeigte sich dass fast
die hälfte der ausgaben an ein
unternehmen gegangen waren von dem ich
noch nie gehört hat eine winzig kleine
firma an der westküste kanadas die
offenbar vorher noch nie eine politische
kampagne durchgeführt hatte niemand
wusste wirklich wer diese firma war
sie beantwortete nicht mal meine e mails
wer steckt hinter dieser mysteriösen
firma warum bekam sie das viele geld
die erfolgreiche kampagne hat ein
großteil des geldes für etwas ausgegeben
von dem wir fast nichts wussten es war
eine art schwarzes loch derweil nutzten
nigel farage und alan bangs ihren ruhm
und ließen sich als vorbilder und
inspiration im us-wahlkampf feiern
weil sie die glauben dass man unsere
zukunft am besten als nationalstaat
organisieren sollte stehen sich auf der
ganzen welt sehr nah ich komme aus dem
vereinigten königreich mit einer
botschaft der hoffnung das tram team
fand das sehr hilfreich vier monate vor
der wahl diese große dosis praxis
verabreicht zu bekommen auch donald
trumps kampagne setzte nun das erprobte
know how aus europa ein präzisions
propaganda verdeckter anzeigen das ganze
repertoire zu dem zeitpunkt fragte sich
eine britische journalistin wie die
wahlen der zukunft gewonnen werden
kurz vor den us wahlen begann ich mich
dafür zu interessieren wie neue
technologien den wahlkampf beeinflussen
das war mein einstieg am ende begriff
ich dass es dieses riesige des
informations system gab der journalistin
gelang es einen insider zum reden zu
bringen
der berichtete dass cambridge analytica
facebook daten illegal benutzt hatte um
in den usa wähler zu manipulieren
betroffen 80 millionen menschen das
zeigt was diese menschen und unternehmen
tun um zu gewinnen und sie alle spielten
auch eine zentrale rolle beim break als
er mir in unserem ersten gespräch
berichtete was er mit den facebook-daten
gemacht hatte und wie sie verwendet
werden konnten standen mir die haare im
nacken zu berge
aber der insider berichtet noch
brisanteres viele der publikationen die
als grundlage für unsere methoden
verwendet wurden basierten auf
forschungen der universität in cambridge
ein teil davon wurde von dem us militär
forschungsinstitut data finanziert
cambridge analytiker hatte auch direkte
aufträge für das militär übernommen
dabei ging es oft darum die
verhaltensmuster von menschen im ausland
zu manipulieren um diese methoden zu
entwickeln arbeiteten sie mit darpa
zusammen der forschungsagentur des us
militärs genau wie mit dem britischen
ponto und dann verkauften sie dieses
know how it profis sagten mir alle
unternehmen und politikberater gehen so
vor genau wie bei obama aber hier geht
es um einen militärischen dienstleister
der in afghanistan aufträge des us
verteidigungsministeriums und der nato
ausgeführt hat und jetzt diese technik
hier einsetzt um eine zivilbevölkerung
zu beeinflussen
fast alle organisierten eu-gegner
griffen auf verdeckte anzeigen zurück
auch die mode lief kampagne die das
brett lager offiziell anführte
wie weit wird lief dabei ging weiß ja
nie
er hat als freiwilliger bei der kampagne
gearbeitet
ich konnte dort erfahrung in der politik
sein
boris johnson kam jeden zweiten tag zu
uns ins büro
dort lief gab sich zunächst moderater
als etwa die gruppe von neun schiffe
rasch und alan bangs nach dem wort lief
die offizielle kampagne geworden war
setzte man fast nur noch auf kernthemen
von denen man wusste dass sie die
menschen bewegt die türkei migration
die daten hatten zuvor gesagt benutzt
das benutzt dass viele menschen in der
politik her wissen dass sie schnell
erfolg haben wenn sie diese vor
imperiale fantasie einfach auch die
kampagne von boris johnson streute die
propaganda verdeckt sie nutzte dabei wie
andere eu gegner das know-how jener
firma die auf digitalen wahlkampf
spezialisiert war
das mysteriöse kanadische unternehmen
acd lief wusste wie mächtig akku und die
algorithmen waren
wie genau man damit menschen erreichen
konnte deshalb brach lief das gesetz in
der firma noch mehr geld zahlen zu
können
in großbritannien darf eine kampagne nur
eine bestimmte summe ausgeben
gut lief hatte diese obergrenze schnell
erreicht um das gesetz zu umgehen
gründete man ableger darunter die
jugendbewegung belief schami wurde ihr
chef und erhielt kurz darauf eine große
spende
wir wussten anfangs noch nicht dass sie
lief nur als erfüllungsgehilfe benutzt
wurde
ich durfte das geld nicht einsetzen
obwohl ich schatzmeister und
forschungsdirektor bei alles musste
direkt zu eric rubin
bei love in den letzten zwei wochen gab
es fast 100.000 pfund pro tag für
werbung aus während ich mir kaum essen
leisten konnte
schaaf mir schlägt rechnungen vor die
belegen dass akku gewaltige summen bekam
700.000 und können viel bewirken
auf facebook zum beispiel auf facebook
für werbung und vor allem wenn sie so
perfekt zugeschnitten ist die
wahlkommission verurteilte pooth lief
aufgrund der aussage des whistleblowers
zu einer geldstrafe mehr sehen die
gesetze nicht vor den vorteil hatten
sich die eu gegner da längst verschafft
wer behauptet dass das brett referendum
legitim zustande gekommen ist liegt wohl
gut lief hat gewonnen weil sie ärzte und
das gesetz brach wenige monate nach dem
referendum gewinnt auch donald trump
überraschend die us-präsidentschaftswahl
sein berater brennan und er hatten
weiter auf die methoden gesetzt die sich
beim eu referendum bewährt hatten
lügen und propaganda sind dabei mittel
mit denen die wähler mobilisiert werden
zu den ersten gratulanten gehören nigel
farage und sein finanziellen banks im
archiv material stoßen wir auf eine
interessante begegnung
nigel farage trifft in der lobby des
traktors der milliardär robert moser
wichtigster geldgeber des neuen
präsidenten und mitbesitzer vieler
firmen darunter die wahlkampf
spezialisten cambridge analytiker und
[Musik]
acer hat zwar nicht die facebook
anzeigen bezahlt aber die gründung der
firmen finanziert die wiederum die
technologie hinter den anzeigen
entwickelt haben alles teile von mosers
imperium
mercer ist durch seinen hedgefonds reich
geworden renntag in dem unscheinbaren
gebäude werden milliarden mit
finanzgeschäften gemacht vor allem dank
komplexer computerprogramme der partner
von banks andy dittmar machte nicht nur
ständig self eis sondern gab schon 2016
vor der journalistin mit mörser an
natürlich wollten robert moser und steve
barron uns helfen denn die trump
kampagne und wir hatten genau die
gleichen ziele
wir sind wie eine familie er sagte
neuester stand im mittelpunkt einer
gruppe von milliardären die ihren
einfluss und daten nutzten um die
westliche gesellschaft zu verändern hat
der us-amerikaner mercer die eu-gegner
auch finanziell unterstützt nach
britischem recht wäre das verboten
ich habe nie geld von robert maaser
bekomme niemals die bread kampagne haben
angeblich ausschließlich einheimische
spender finanziert wie alan bangs eine
parlamentskommission setzte sich mit dem
unternehmer auseinander
der mann sollte erklären woher die neun
millionen pfund genau stammten die er
gespendet hatte
er konnte nie erklären woher das geld
genau kam mit welchem geschäft oder mit
welcher seiner firmen er es verdient hat
er sagte nur das geld stammt aus meinem
privaten rücklagen aber es gibt
inzwischen so viele zweifel an dieser
erklärung dass die national crime agency
ermittlungen aufgenommen hat
auch wir gehen der spur nach er in bands
vertreibt in einem vorort von
restschuldversicherungen er behauptet
dort 1000 angestellte zu haben doch in
dem bürogebäude hat er nur zwei
stockwerke angemietet kaum die zentrale
eines unternehmens das laut banks 200
millionen pfund wert ist viele tische in
dem callcenter sind leer
die journalistin gemeinschaft open dem
opfers hat die finanzen von alan bangs
untersucht alle öffentlichen unterlagen
gesammelt
ein spezialist analysierte die daten
eher entwertet das komplizierte geflecht
von banks firmen im ausland
es ist schwer nachzuvollziehen woher
banks 9 millionen pfund hatte um sie in
den wechsel zu investieren denn er stand
damals selber unter enormen druck musste
geld auftreiben damit seine firmen
flüssig blieben bank versicherung in
gibraltar registriert stand am abgrund
die finanzbehörden in gibraltar machten
klar dass er 50 millionen pfund
auftreiben musste um das kapital in der
firma aufzustocken
woher dann diese summe kam wie genau das
geld erst nach gibraltar und dann weiter
nach großbritannien fließen konnte ist
ein rätsel
wer rettete damals errang banks stimmt
die geschichte vom superreichen
versicherungs tycoon die er selbst so
gern erzählt überhaupt wie kann jemand
dessen wichtigste firma gefahr läuft
bankrott zu gehen nicht einmal zwölf
monate später zum größten politischen
spender in der britischen geschichte
werde
mitten in seiner persönlichen
finanzkrise wurde bei hengst nicht nur
zum politischen großspender er kaufte
zudem mehrere diamanten minen in
südafrika und brüstete sich damit
er erregte großes aufsehen mit der
ankündigung dass er mehrere diamanten
ihnen gekauft hatte
doch wie handfest war dieses geschäft
wirklich wenn diese medien gar nicht so
wertvoll waren was hat das ganze dann
für einen sinn
aus dem bk wurden die diamanten 1
tonnenweise geholt auch banks und seine
partner besuchten die legendäre aber
schon längst geflutete miene
in der nähe des bag auf der airbase 2015
drei diamanten minen als symbol für
seinen angeblichen reichtum er schauen
sie uns an die erste mine sieht
verlassen aus wir fragen den nachbarn
gegenüber
ich bin seit 15 jahren hier 15 jahre
nicht nein
wenige kilometer weiter eine zweite mine
sofort kommt ein wachmann
es ist ihnen nicht erlaubt hier bilder
zu machen
wer hat ihnen die erlaubnis dazu gegeben
ist diese mine noch aktiv sind die sp
arbeiter das weiß ich nicht wir noch
nicht lange hier in einem video gab
banks damit an dass zumindest diese mine
aktiv sei und dort viele diamanten
gefunden werden nicht nur wir haben
zweifel
[Musik]
in johannesburg treffen wir einen anwalt
der die korruption im land bekämpft er
hat banks verklagt weil er angeblich mit
unregistrierten diamanten gehandelt
haben soll
e mails von banks erwecken diesen
verdacht und noch mehr war seltsam
es kann nicht einfach eine alte mine
kaufen bei der eine andere firma gesagt
hat nun wir haben genug von dieser mine
sie ist fertig und jetzt kommt er und
fängt plötzlich an gewinn zu machen
das gibt es nicht wenn eine mine am ende
ist ist sie am ende
ich glaube nicht dass sie dort überhaupt
diamanten finden er behauptet auf seiner
webseite alle diamanten stammen aus sein
was ist eine lüge das team von
o'sullivan hat zweifel ob das überhaupt
der eigentümer terminen ist behauptet
ihm gehören diese aber wenn man mit dem
zuständigen ministerium spricht hört man
stimmt nicht er nutzt andere personen
als strohmänner auch deshalb hat er
viele fragen zu beantworten
wir bekommen einen tipp banks hatte
einen geschäftspartner verklagt und
musste deshalb eigene unterlagen offen
legen
wir beantragen akteneinsicht in einer
digitalen kopie findet sich ein
interessanter hinweis ende 2015 als er
gerade aktiv in die politik einstieg
suchte banks laut eines
geschäftspartners für die minen
investoren auch in russland längst
verheiratet mit einer russin reiste
mehrmals nach moskau und nicht nur das
aber ende 2015 ist der regelmäßig in der
russischen botschaft in london zu gast
ein geheimdienstmitarbeiter hatte ihn
kontaktiert der botschafter wolle ihn
treffen
er hat eine einladung des russischen
botschafters akzeptiert na und
auch farrar schlich sich 2014 mit dem
botschafter fotografieren
eben dieser botschafter brachte banks
kurz vor dem referendum mit russischen
unternehmern zusammen
man verhandelte über gold und diamanten
geschäfte angeblich ohne erfolg der
größte spender in der politischen
geschichte großbritanniens spricht mit
dem russischen botschafter über gold und
diamantenminen deals das ist nicht
normal
selbstverständlich muss geklärt werden
ob geld das in einer kampagne in
großbritannien geschlossen ist zuvor
durch ein geschäft mit russen verdient
wurde
banks versuchte fortan die vorwürfe
wegzulächeln alles nur eine hexenjagd
vor einem untersuchungsausschuss des
parlaments gab er sich zunächst
entspannt haben sie nach diesen treffen
geschäfte in russland abgeschlossen ich
habe keine geschäftsinteressen in
russland nicht einen einzigen deal doch
weitere fragen beantwortet banks nicht
bricht eine befragung im parlament
einfach ab ich habe eine verabredung zum
mittagessen
ich wäre dankbar wenn sie noch fünf
minuten hätten die antwort ist nein
banks begleitete fahrrad oft in die usa
ist beim wahlkampf von donald trump mit
dabei beim russischen botschafter
berichtet banks anschließend in london
ausführlich über seine treffen mit tram
dann passierte etwas merkwürdiges
[Applaus]
war gerade auf wahlkampftour in den usa
für donald trump als er aus einem
flugzeug in chicago stieg und plötzlich
von fbi-agenten umringt war
dabei wurde sein schatzmeister verhaftet
sie sagten kein wort des fbi mann hat
sie mitgenommen
der mann george mitchell hatte bereits
als private banker gearbeitet war
einfach jemand der hilfreich war
organisierte dinge setzte sie um als
freiwilliger 2014 war cottrell
undercover-agenten des fbi geraten
er bot den agenten an geld für ein
drogenkartell zu waschen control wurde
nicht verhaftet sondern reist nach
england zurück wo er fortan für
verarbeitete
als das fbi cottrell 2016 schnappte
reagierte bankpartner wigmore auf seine
weise schickte fbi dokumente über diesen
fall an die russische botschaft mit der
anmerkung interessiert euch vielleicht
das ist doch verrückt
haben sie die verhaftung von george
control mit der russischen botschaft
thematisieren es war nie thema damals
schien das eine große sache zu sein aber
es war auch sonst so viel los deswegen
war das nie thema
warum bieten sich banks und co so bei
den russen an befolgten sie nur befehle
das fragen wir einen experten der lange
auch russen ausspioniert hat wir müssen
uns von diesem hollywood bild
verabschieden dass der kreml alle fäden
im westen in der hand hält der kreml
passt sich an nutzt die politischen
herausforderungen des westens er aus
denen roxette haben sie nicht
herbeigeführt
sie haben gesehen wie er sich entwickelt
und vergifteten die stimmung weiter
die russen locken banks mit angeblichen
die ltte gerade als seine firma schwer
angeschlagen war längst bis an und wurde
abgeschöpft
russland hat aktive agenten im westen in
der wirtschaft in der politik in den
medien für jeden tatsächlichen agenten
der bewusst etwas für russland tut gibt
es dutzende von nützlichen idioten
[Musik]
das sind menschen die es eigentlich nur
interessiert dass sie selbst immer
reicher werden sie beteiligen sich auch
an fragwürdigen finanzdeals sie wollen
einfach nur das geld ein traum für
russische geheimdienst trump und sein
team planten noch im wahlkampf den bau
eines luxus gebäudes in moskau
sie wollten dabei offenbar trumps
kandidaten bonus zu geld machen
[Musik]
niemand im westen wird von russland
direkt gefragt ob er helfen will
das läuft viel subtiler ab und deswegen
funktioniert es oft irgendwann hängt
eine westliche zielperson zu tief drin
und realisiert zu spät was die russen
genau ausgehängt haben die russischen
geheimdienste spielten beim wechselt er
eine nebenrolle bei der wahl von trump
war ihr einfluss bereits größer sie
sollen nicht nur daten der demokraten
gestohlen haben sondern auch
fehlinformationen über twitter facebook
und instagram gestreut haben zwei
experten haben diese daten für den
us-senat analysiert die russen suchen
nach einer kampagne die erfolgreich die
gesellschaft spaltet und kopieren sie
einfach man erkennt kaum mehr wer wen
imitiert oder wer mit wem hand in hand
arbeitet die firma grafiker hat farblich
visualisiert wer in wessen auftrag bei
der us-wahl fehlinformationen gestreut
hat das grüne sind die russen hier ein
sehr großes russisches team die experten
werteten auch propaganda aus die nach
der wahl verbreitet wurde
was uns auch viel die russische
aktivität ist nach den wahlen auf allen
plattformen instagram twitter facebook
noch stärker geworden russen
rechtsextremisten autokraten sie alle
erkennen dass digitale propaganda
funktioniert
ich glaube nicht dass man die zeit
zurückdrehen kann
das internet polarisiert weil man sich
seine eigene abgeschlossene informations
umgebung schaffen kann leichter als noch
in der alten ära der massenmedien so
polarisiert sich die gesellschaft immer
stärker und diese spaltung wird als
waffe eingesetzt
was eine polarisierte radikalisierte
diskussion in einem land anrichtet zeigt
sich drastisch in großbritannien
bei einer podiumsveranstaltung zum
großen braig sie drauf sind sich die
teilnehmer einig noch lange ist nicht
bekannt wie massiv das referendum
manipuliert wurde
erst dachte ich so verrückt ist es gar
nicht aber dann wurde es jeden tag
verrückter wir wissen schon jetzt dass
dies keine faire abstimmung war immerhin
laufen aktuell 9 strafrechtliche
ermittlungen in der sache und es gibt
belastbare beweise dass sich
ausländische kräfte eingemischt haben
das verblüffende selbst bei einer
manipulation sieht das gesetz keine
wiederholung des referendums vor
wir waren ein leichtes ziel
einige reiche amerikaner haben diese
gelegenheit erkannt so genau wie die
russische regierung dann gab es einzelne
briten die diese möglichkeit ebenfalls
ausgenutzt haben
die versuchung war einfach zu groß weil
es nichts gab was hier aufhalten konnte
mir ist klar geworden wie verwundbar
großbritannien war und die anderen
europäischen länder sind es noch immer
und die aufarbeitung dauert lange zu
lange das beängstigende ist dass wir all
das erst rückblickend herausfinden
die eu gegner haben noch lange nicht
genug 2016 war ein schock für alle
aber dieser bewegung wird sich
weiterentwickeln und am ende das system
verändern können und vorhaben gemeinsam
wie seltene aufnahmen zeigen erfolgreich
menschen mobilisiert und radikalisiert
andere populisten könnten nun ihre
methoden kopieren
ich glaube nicht dass leute wie steve
bahnen sich mit der wahl von trump oder
dem wechsel zufrieden geben sondern die
erfolge als beginn einer bewegung sehen
die kultur und politik verändern will
viele leute beobachten diesen wandel und
sagen er ist hässlich er ist spaltend
nationalistisch populistisch und könnte
dämonen in europa frei setzen von denen
wir dachten dass wir sie vor langer zeit
besiegt hätten die eu wurde auch
gegründet damit der ungeist nicht nach
europa zurückkehrt
nun müssen die institutionen dort mühsam
versuchen die digitale propaganda
zurückzudrängen
der zuständige kommissar ein brite hat
analysieren lassen wie groß die
bedrohung bereits ist wir haben
festgestellt dass es ein muster geben
weltweit gab es bereits 30 versuche
wahlen zu manipulieren oder zerstören
der kommissar verspricht auf einer
veranstaltung die sich kritisch mit der
rolle von facebook auseinandersetzt
dass sich die eu wehren wird wir bauen
ein netzwerk auf das als
schnellwarnsystem konzipiert ist um
desinformations angriffe abzuwehren die
sich über mehrere medien und länder
verteilt haben ist das system
einsatzbereit
nein aber in ein paar wochen obwohl die
eu nur bedingt abwehrbereit ist will man
propaganda und gezielten
desinformationen nicht verbieten ein
wahrheit' ministerium wäre nicht der
richtige weg
wir werden uns auf europäischer ebene
auch nicht darauf einigen dass man
jemanden einsatz der beurteilt ob ein
politischer inhalt war richtig oder
falsch ist denn das wäre am ende so ist
man in der eu auf die hilfe der
digitalen mega konzerne angewiesen
darunter facebook mark zuckerberg firma
soll nun wenigstens die quellen von
politischen anzeigen offenlegen
freiwillig dabei hält der konzern bis
heute viele anzeigen der radikalen
eu-gegner unter verschluss zudem wurden
die facebook mache gerade vom britischen
parlament als digitale gangster
beschrieben
ausgerechnet facebook also als
schutzwall
hat man aus dem rexit nichts gelernt es
besteht die gefahr in eine neue krise zu
stolpern und die menschen verschließen
davor einfach die augen
die digitalisierung verändert den alltag
die kommunikation die demokratie die
alten strukturen sind von dieser
revolution überfordert obwohl sie gerade
erst beginnt wir stehen erst am anfang
dieser entwicklung wir müssen verstehen
dass diese veränderungen ein großes maß
an angst unsicherheit und politischen
verwerfungen mit sich bringen werden
die gefahr besteht dass in dieser
situation gewaltsame konflikte
ausbrechen und das müssen wir verhindern
doch die öffentlichkeit nimmt diese
bedrohung kaum war die politik nutzt
ihre macht nicht konzerne denken nur an
ihren umsatz
so verliert die westliche gesellschaft
den kampf um die demokratie
[Musik]